[Music]
[Applause]
hello everybody so before I get started
I was just curious how many people here
work for a company that does continuous
delivery already
or maybe a few how many of you you do
continuous
deployment a few of you okay so this
talk is aimed at beginners it's really
any of people who have not done much
continuous delivery before so if you are
an expert or doing it already this may
not be the talk for you so get lots of
beer tell me afterwards why everything
I've said is completely wrong and please
bear with me I'll tell you things you
may already know and for everybody else
let's get
going so hey I'm Lisa van gelder I am a
consultant at Cyrus innovation is a
consultancy company in New York I'm very
much at the dev end of devop so before I
worked for Cyrus I was at the Guardian
newspaper in London for many years where
I headed up the team that did the
comment system and also the team did the
response system which is a team that
dealt with uh problems in production I
worked very closely with the operations
team to make sure the site was stable
and working
properly so why this talk so I've been
to some really amazing talks this year
from companies like Google and Facebook
and Netflix about continuous delivery
and continuous deployment and I've come
out of those talks and I've talked
people in the audience what they said to
me is yeah that's fantastic if you have
the budget of Google or Facebook if you
have those kind of numbers of developers
it's fantastic you can do it but the
rest of us we don't have those kind of
budgets we can't afford to throw
Hardware at the problem like Facebook
and have one server per test the way
that they do so continuous delivery it's
only for the big companies it's not for
the small ones and this talk is ready to
say that is not true that everyone can
do continuous
delivery so first of all people a lot of
people confuse continuous delivery and
continuous deployment they're actually
not the same thing so continuous
delivery is not about automating
everything it's really about trying to
find the bottlenecks that be delivering
things and removing those
bottlenecks so I'm going to start by
talking through briefly what continuous
deployment is and then tell you what
continuous is in comparison so what this
is is an example pipeline for continuous
deployment the pipeline might not look
exactly like this it's just an example
of what it might look like so basically
what it is is a series of checkpoints
Each of which tries to prove that the
code is not fit to release to production
so it's impossible to prove the absence
of bugs only prove the presence of bugs
so each checkpoint will try to prove
that there are bugs if if they find bugs
the deploy the whole build stops the
build goes back back to the first stage
developers stop what they're doing they
fix the issue and then the bill kicks
off again from
beginning so it starts out when
developers check in to
master the next stage is continuous
integration so the code that's just been
checked into Master it's checked with
the rest of code that's already there so
tests are run against all the code to
make sure the code will integrate with
it here it's been F into two different
checkpoints it may or may not be SP in
two different things the first one is
unit test which will test code either
methods or objects in isolation the
second one exception test or integration
test this is where you're testing the
combination of several objects or
several things all together quite
possibly by something like selenium
which will actually drive a web
browser after that if there are no
problems with continuous
integration performance tests are run so
the code the code is deployed to
performance test environment automatic
performance tests run if there are no
performance regressions code will
automatically be deployed maybe to a
canary test
environment so Canary tests this is bit
like a canary in a CO mine you don't
deploy the codes to all the servers at
the beginning you deploy the codes any
percentage of the servers maybe maybe 1%
maybe
5% and you just look to see how the code
behaves if there are no problems with
those servers then the code is R rolled
out to rest the servers in production so
that point the canary test stage has
been passed so note that all this is
completely automatic so there is no
human intervention but Cod has gone
straight from a developer checking in to
master decoding live in production but
also note that quality is still assured
because there are checkpoints at every
stage making sure that quality is still
there also note that it's although it's
automatic it's not instant so some of
these checkpoints might take a while to
run particularly things like acception
test or performance test if they're long
running tests
that's awesome but most of us don't work
in an environment that is quite that
automated so a lot of us have work in
environment which is a bit more like
this which is exactly same as the last
one but now they're humans involved so a
lot of this is not quite automatic
anymore so typically this will start out
in the same way a developer checks in
code to master and then continuous
integration is kicked off we're all
testing with unit test integration test
but then after that humans so that's
quite proberly a human who is going to
choose when to deploy to the QA
environment and humans will run manual
QA tests to make sure that uh all the
code still
works also humans will run performance
tests and humans will also choose when
to deploy to
production quite often there actually
make sense you might have a a product
manager who wants to make the call on
when exactly is a good time deployed
production you might have operations
people who want to make the call on when
exactly a good time is to deploy perhaps
there are there are peak times and other
times maybe there's something you want
to keep an eye on before to just
suddenly go live so it's actually fine
to have humans in some of these
things the point isn't really that you
mustn't have humans anywhere it's really
about measuring the time it takes you to
get from one end to the other end so the
the complete time it takes to get from
check in to master coding live in
production it's called cycle time and
it's important to to measure that and to
move to remove blockers that make that
quicker
because hey this is an F-16 fighter
jet there was a really smart man called
John Boyd who watched Planes fight in
Korea and he Sol the problem that mer
had been working on for quite a while
which is what makes fighter jets most
efficient is it the armor is it the
speed of the plane is it the weapons
that they have and what John Boyd
realized is actually that the thing that
most often correlates to success is the
reaction time of the plane that is the
time in which the plane reacts to the
Pilot's input telling it what to do so
if you're in a dog fight if you can make
six decisions and your opponent can make
three decisions you're not guaranteed to
win but you are to Inn your
favor so what John Boyd came up with is
the concept of think this thing called
Ute which stands for observe Orient
decide and act so the first thing that
you do if if you want to do something is
you You observe so you see what's going
on what's what's the enemy fighter doing
he's climbing up okay then you Orient
what does that mean
from past experience if it's going up
it's going to come down again in a
minute to come get you you decide then
you decide what to do based on your
observations and your knowledge of past
actions and then you act you go through
a lot of these UD loop with every every
fight they get into but because every
one of these is actually based on
observations the more of these that you
go through the more likely likely it is
that you're going to make a good
decision
the other thing is that if you can react
faster than your opponent you can
actually make them act on old data so if
you can put your decisions into actions
quicker than they can even though they
can see what you're doing they can still
observe if their plane is taking too
long to respond to their
decision you're you again you're in a
much better
position and John Boyd's thinking has
actually really impacted the way that
modern Fighters are built so the picture
of the F16 that's based on John Boy's
work so what's that got to do with
software
development it actually comes back to
this idea of cycle time again the time
it takes to get from checkin to mastered
coding in production this is the cycle
time of your
organization by the time you get to here
your organization has already gone
through the first BD of an UDA Loop so
you have already observed you've looked
to see what your competitors are doing
you've oriented so you've decided what
what that means you made a decision for
what you want to do and now you want to
put that decision and action so just the
same way as with with anop with
Fighters if your company can can make
six decisions and your competitors can
make three decisions you're not
guaranteed to win but you're in a good
position just the same way is with the
fighters you can act quicker than your
competitors you can disrupt their UDA
Loops so you can make them act on all
information again this puts you in a
much better position so this is why it's
important to both measure your cycle
time and to try and reduce it as much as
you possibly can
when I say measure your cycle time it's
actually important to measure the whole
of your cycle time so it doesn't help if
you reduce the time it takes to do one
of the bits one of the check checkpoints
if that increases the time of the other
checkpoints the thing that you want to
reduce is the whole cycle time Al
together so this is the point that
continues to L to measure the total
cycle time to reduce the cycle time and
to improve the reaction time with your
organization so fantastic how do you
choose where start with doing
this so one really good place to start
is to double the frequency of your
releases so you still releasing the same
amount of code but letting it into
smaller chunks to release each
individual chunk much more quickly and
actually just just doing smaller
releases have a lot of benefits all by
itself code has value in production code
doesn't have value on your C service so
get it to production
quicker there's a lot less coordination
required if you're doing smaller
releases and bigger releases because
you're only t T in the integration
between your one small feature and
production rather than your feature and
every other feature to be released at
the same time and production it's much
so it's much easier to test it's much
easier to see if your one feature caus
issues in production because you know it
was that just went live whereas if you
have 60 things that went live it's much
more hard to tell which one it was and
it's much easier to roll back one thing
than 60
things a brief side note if you can't if
you can't actually release it f good so
there are some people who working in EN
environments where it's actually really
hard to do small releases to production
sometimes you really just have to do one
or
two for
example if you are in this kind of
situation you can still get a lot of the
benefits of doing smaller releases by
just faking it so go through all the
same steps that you normally go through
to do a production release but instead
of actually releasing production release
to a test
environment so if you just try and
double the frequency of releases you
probably find that you can't do it
there'll be absolute blockers that stop
you and those blockers are really
interesting because those blockers are
probably some of the bottlenecks in your
process and fixing those those bottle LS
is a really good place to start for
speeding out your cycle
time this is the road map of this talk
today so these are some of the blockers
that I have encountered you've prob
found your own ones these are some of my
top ones I'm going to talk through these
and some of the ways we've solved them
at most you have the guardian
actually so first of all it's really
hard to just do more releases when
releases cause problems for
users so the first team I worked on at
the Guardian newspaper was the team that
looked after the content management
system so this is a system that
published all the Guardians journalism
to the
website and we were an agile team so we
released every two weeks and the release
process for the CMS meant that we had to
take the CMS down completely for 20
minutes to do an upgrade that is we
asked all the journalists at the
guardian to stop working for 20 minutes
to to log out system while we while we
could upgrade the system uh there's a
problem with that the news doesn't work
that way it's actually really hard to
get all journal to stop working at any
point news is actually 24-hour cycle
there is no real good time to do a
release so this caused pain for
everybody it caused pain for the
journalists because we asked them to
stop working for a while it caused pain
for developers because we kept having
releases rescheduled we come in early
and endings would get canceled some big
news event came along so this whole
thing was very painful we need we have
to do something about it so the reason
that we had to take the CMS down
completely for 20 minutes are actually
two of them one of which is that
database change changes were very
closely tied to code changes the other
one there was a far too much state in
the
session so for the first one data base
changes tied to code changes we had an
RM an object relational mapper called
hibernate which we use to build mappings
between the code and the
database uh if the mappings in hibernate
were out of date as those mappings not
in single dat B hibernate would not load
there would be no website so in order to
make sure that this happened we had
automatic schema changes run with every
deploy so developer would check
something in automatic changes would
happen we didn't want to risk
journalists making updates to tables
while we were in the middle of upgrading
them so we asked everyone to log out
completely actually the fix for this was
actually just a process change so what
we did is we decoupled the schem of
changes from the deploy we said from
this point on if you check something in
it will not run
we asked developers to manually make
make changes to database before any
release went out so how the hell does
that work so say you want to add a new
column to a table the first thing you do
is you run the update in in production
to add the new column and at some point
later on you deploy the code that
expects the new column to be there but
those two things that have you on at the
same time the code before that didn't
expect the column to be there and you
can still roll back because code before
that did not expect the did not expect
column to be there no problem if you
want to delete a column the first thing
that you do is you deploy the code that
does not expect the column to be there
and then you wait a while because you
don't want to delete the column straight
away because that means that you can't
roll the code back we discovered though
that we very rarely rolled back more
than a few releases at a time so once
we've done a few releases after the the
code was deployed it didn't rely on the
column anymore it save to delete the
column the thing that we're really
worried about which was uh the Happ
mappings getting out of sync actually
never happened simply because we we put
the developers who were writing the code
in charge of actually running the deploy
script the database change
scripts we asked them to do that if
they're adding new things before any of
the code went out there's no there's no
possible chance that the code will be
deployed without the column because you
can't check into Master if the column
has not been
added and for the delete deltion of the
column well if that took a little bit
little while to happen no harm was done
and what what this meant is that we
could deploy without worrying about
tables being
changed the second thing that we had to
do was get rid of lot state in the
session so we had some incredibly
complicated web forms with lots and lots
of fields on them take a long time to
fill in and the complete state of this
web forms was all saved in session on
the server so if a server went away
because it was for example being
deployed to before a journalist had
pressed save or publish all that work
would be lost so there was a lot of work
if the first one was just a process
change this actually took several months
was to remove all the state from all our
forms so every form would post back the
the full state of the form in Json to
the server so it didn't matter which
server you were on anymore you could
post uh to any
server and if one server went down and
other one was being deployed to it
didn't matter because the for St was in
Jason nothing got lost at the end of all
this what we ended up with was down
times was no downtime deployments so we
could deploy pretty much at will from
every two weeks to to anytime to several
times a day this made everybody very
happy but that's not any
bottleneck so another really common
bottleneck for just doing more releases
is when releases cause performance
problems so obviously every now and then
something goes wrong unexpectedly this
is more like if there if there are
performance problems regularly
this probably means that there's a
missing performance test somewhere in
which case add them what means that
performance tests maybe don't accurately
reflect what's going on in production so
if you're not already doing this it's
handy to get logs from production and
then play them back in a test
environment so you're actually
reflecting the way the production is
really
used if there are things like memory
leaks and performance tests are running
too quickly to pick up slow long long
running memory leaks things like soak
test can really help with which is just
performance test when over a longer
periods of time maybe every a few hours
even over a weekend to pick up some of
the longer running
issues if you are releasing a new bit of
functionality maybe even a whole new
application and you have no idea what
the performance characteristic is going
to be like yet then dark launches can
also be really helpful so a dark launch
is where you put something into
production but don't tell users about it
yet probably it's only visible within
your own
environment we did this at the guardian
for the new comment system system so
when before we turned the new comment
system on we'd already written some
performan St we wanted to make sure that
it was really accurate for how it's
being used in production so we added
some some JavaScript on the old comment
system which did asynchronous call to
the new comment system we gradually
wrapped it up so first of all we had it
only on a page then on a whole section
and gradually across the whole site and
by the end of it we were invisibly
sending the full production traffic of
the old comment system to the new
comment system without any impact on
users which all synchronous which meant
that by the time the new common system
was turned on we knew that it could cope
with the full load it had already been
doing it for a couple of weeks and even
though we had performance tests we had
get we had guessed the way the Mohave in
production it turns out those
performance tests were not good enough
users s user system exactly the way they
we expected them to so the dark PL is
really really
helpful and finally performance test as
soon as you can so as a developer I get
really excited about getting all the
features done getting something out to
production it's really easy to leave
performance testing till the very end uh
it's very expensive to fix basic
problems if you leave it until the end
like if there are problems with your
architecture problems with uh the
hosting environment to which your
application is deployed it's much better
to find it out at the beginning of the
process then at the end so what I like
to do is if I'm building something
entirely new run an end to-end test as
soon as I possibly can soon as there's
anything to test then you can get the
Baseline tests for your systems you can
get the base your response times you
can't build all your performance tests
at the beginning you don't that you know
what you're going to be testing yet you
can start of go on thinking about it and
as you add new features you can see how
those baselines change it's really
useful oh another potential blocker if
releases routinely break existing
functionality so often if I go to a new
place I know this is going to the case
if the deployed to production is under
at a really strange time time if it's
done really late at night it's done
really early in the morning then over
the weekend this is because releases
routinely break functionality for users
so releases can't be done when users are
on the site there a couple of really
common causes for this one of which is
again missing tests if you find that you
having the same problems over and over
again make sure they're test for them
another really common cause for this is
if there's no environment that is close
enough to production to test on so it's
really important to have at least one
environment that is an exact scaled on
replica production with everything that
production has on it every firewall rule
every external system everything that it
does because you can be sure that the
one thing that your production system
has and your test system does not have
that's the one thing it's going to break
really badly in
production and this is what happened for
our comment system so when my lovely
very heavy tested comment system finally
went live a whole bunch of its
functionality just didn't work so we
looked at our servers and the whole
bunch of requests just never actually
hit our servers
the difference between production and
our test environment was a CDN was
basically supposed to be acting as
invisible cache so it was supposed to
just forward on every request it didn't
know what to do with it couldn't respond
to straight on to our servers we
discovered in production that it didn't
allow zero length posts so there were a
bunch of posts that we had because we
have had rest URLs where all the
information that the server needed was
actually in the URL so there's no
information being sent for the post but
it was a post because it's not item
poent is making changes this can't be
again it B like that the CDN at those
requests they never for didn't forward
them on just didn't allow them no no
error messages no nothing just quietly
ate the whole
thing so we had to roll back uh a
production release workup but the thing
was it roll forward if we had a CDN and
our test environment we could have found
that a lot less publicly which would
have been way better and the fix for
this by the way was really simple all we
had to do is add a really can test
string they didn't matter what what the
string was and then these requests would
go straight through very easy to fix
very painful to find in
production another really common blocker
for getting more releases done is if the
operation scene just don't have time to
do more releases that buy got more
important things to be
doing well we all know ideally that
deploy a deploy should look a lot like
that should be really simple right I
have worked at a whole bunch of places
it looks a lot more like
that so these these kind of releases
they're stressful they take an expert
things can go wrong if you if you ask
operation te to just do a few more of
these kind of releases every day they're
going to get quite unhappy with you for
for a good reason no one ever intends to
have a deployment system that looks like
this often it ends up this way when
product managers and other people who
are prioritizing work really prioritize
features ahead of trying to get the
deploy script sorted out
one team I know fixed this by giving the
entire deploy process to the
developers so developers were trained in
how to deploys they were trained in how
to monitor the releases to make sure
that the releases were going okay and
then the entire the entire system was
just hand it over to them and as if by
Magic within a few weeks the system
looked a lot more like
that the point of this is not to say
developers sh building operations work
the point is actually about pain points
so quite often in an organization when
when there is a pain point the person
who is causing the pain is not the same
person who has to deal with the pain if
you get the chance to give the person
who can actually actually had the
opportunity to fix the pain to give them
the pain the pain just goes
away here is another really common
blocker when operations and developers
don't have time to watch releases so
this happens for a bunch of reasons but
the symptoms are that relase interrupts
normal work so you have to C your away
from what they normally doing team has
to be on standby in case of
issues you have to actively interrupt
their day so one of the causes of this
is when it's not very easy to see what's
going on with the system I love
monitoring monitoring one things is
fantastic but it's quite easy to get
overwhelmed with graphs particularly
when they're not really obvious they're
not really easy to read
what I like to do is to make sure that
each team has their own graph which is
Meaningful to them so make sure that
that
developers have graphs map out all to
the system that they care about as a
developer if I've just done a release
and I know that one of my metrics has
just massively changed I'm probably the
right person to know about that and fix
it so I knew that we would had
monitoring right at the guardian when I
went to lunch one day and I came back my
product manager told me he was worried
that we broke something with the last
comments release because the number of
comments that were posted that lunchtime
were way down what was normally posted
on Monday lunchtime and he was right had
grph good enough for everyone on the
team to
understand another really good thing
roll
backs the risk of a release is much
higher when a roll back isn't possible
if it's not possible the roll the code
back quickly to a good known State you
are relying on having the whole team on
hand to to find the problem and you're
relying on the team fixing the problem
without causing more issues it's
actually really stressful when
something's going on wrong in production
if the only way is to roll forward if
there is no roll back you risk people
rushing to get something out to
production actually make the problem
even
worse so roll backs you really be a
normal operation not a failure if
something's going wrong users don't care
about your new feature if the site is
down so it should be possible to roll
back IDE it should be quick to roll
back
this is just an example of a system
where it's fantastically easy to roll
back this is Google app engine it gives
you a list of all the latest releases
that you have and you can do a roll back
just by clicking on the number of
release that you want and making that
public done fantastic make it that
easy a release should be a
non-event done in working hours easy to
monitor easy to roll back if you have
that the whole theme doesn't have to be
standby anymore if you are just
releasing one feature into production
and it's really easy to see what it's
doing the worst thing that's going to
happen is that one feature is going to
get rolled back done doesn't have to
take a whole bunch of your team time to
get it
done another very common Bott L
particularly when QA is doing a whole
bunch of manual testing when QA don't
have time to
test
I've been in a lot of meetings like this
this is an example IPM where developers
and qas are signing up for the amount of
story points that they think they can
get done in iteration but there's a
problem with this the problem is that
developer Capac developer capacity is
far higher than QA capacity so you can
see that by the time we have got to the
Second Story all the QA capacity for the
iteration has already been taken up but
developers are still signing up for more
work so what that means is even in the
best case scenario you're going to
release these features one by one by the
time you get to the third feature you're
going to have a delay because the QA
there's no way that the QA is ever going
to test it for you and this is going to
be
cumulative so that QA capacity is not
getting any bigger so right now the
capacity is six next iteration is going
to be three could you soon it's actually
going to be negative if you don't do
anything about it so often we get into
this kind of situation where people
think okay so this this Cura capacity is
temporary going to hiire more Cur people
are going to come back with holiday
things are going to change
the trouble is that may not actually
happen you don't know what's going to
happen in the future it's better to
actually work with the capacity that you
have so if you only have a very small QA
capacity you can't use them for manual
tests in the way that you want to you
have to be a bit smarter about it one
good way to do this is to get Cur to act
a bit more like Consultants so rather
than Cur doing a whole bunch of manual
testing cures get together with
developers discuss with developers how
they would test the features and get
Developers the
tests so developers activate more like
QA that capacity 17 and six put it
together the important thing is that
these these stories get tested the
important thing is not about who tests
them these kind of cross functional
issues it's actually not just about QA
developers there's a whole bunch of
different cost functional team issues
which which can come along waiting for
designs waiting waiting for ux Wai
product product manager sign off a whole
bunch of different
things and they're all equally bad
so this is an example board for an
iteration showing what state whole bunch
of stories are
in and you can see that there are
several stories that are
blocked this is a terrible
sign code decays so the longer that you
leave code blocked so maybe some work's
been started but it can't be finished
it's waiting for another team the longer
the code is left in that block State the
less useful it's going to be the best
case scenario is that at some point it's
going to get unlocked it's going to get
merged back into Master have got out
some maybe some bad merge comments it's
going to get there the worst case is
that by the time that story gets
unblocked the code is not useful anymore
rest of the code bases moved on you just
waited a whole bunch of development Time
by building this block of
things
so ignoring a whole bunch of stories
from the Block status like that is the
equivalent of of ignoring a whole bunch
of broken tests on Master this is a
warning sign it says something has gone
wrong with your
reparation so if you get into this kind
of state don't just continue don't just
add more stories onto it actively try
and unlock those stories so can someone
else do the
work like with creating developers can
someone else act as a QA can someone
else act as ux can someone else act as
product and someone else make those
decisions whatever it is that you have
to do to get those stories
moving and ideally don't start a story
all the resources is not available if
you know that your story relies on ux
and on design don't start it if they're
not there it's just going to waste of
effort blockers should block don't just
keep adding more stories onto blockers F
it's not going to help you when work is
held up can someone else perform that
function another really common blocker
to getting things out if it takes too
long to get a green build that is a
build on CI where all the tests are
green why does this
happen it could be because a lot of
flaky tests so a definition of of a
flaky test is a is a test which does not
always pass or fail so if you're on it
several times you're going to get
different results or if you run it on
your CI server it fails but it passes
locally these tests are really evil they
are the tests that cry W because they
lead they lead you to reduced confidence
in your test Suite so as soon as you
know that you have flaky tests you know
that Master is red but it's not really
red because you know this one test is
it's kind of it's kind of a flake it
encourages you to not treat brakes on
Master seriously it's quite possible
that if you know you have flaky tests
that you will start to release code to
environments maybe even production when
Master is read and that's a terrible
slippy sleep to go along because okay
sure this one test was actually a Fleek
but maybe tomorrow you ignore a test and
that that was actually a real test now
you've released something which you
should have picked up before it went
into production and it's got out there
so if you find that you have leaky tests
don't let them build up isolate them
quickly
neither fix them or delete them because
a flaky test does not give you any value
if it breaks you're not going to pay any
attention to it anyway so if you can't
fix it quickly just get rid of
it slow running
tests more than 5 minutes for your
complete test Suite to run is slow and
it starts being a waste to developer
time because either they are waiting for
the test run to complete or else they're
getting on with new work and then
they're going to be interrupted and then
you work in context which when tests
break on their test one they're going to
have to go back to fix it so you're
going to interrupt the flow of
development to fix the
tests and if your if your tests are very
slow like maybe more than half an hour
you RK developers not waiting for tests
to finish before they check into Master
because they think I'll just change one
small thing it's going to be fine and
now suddenly you're in a state where
it's really hard to go to Greenville
because Master's continuously broken
because people aren't waiting to see if
they're tested on the
screen so it's important to get these
test running as soon as you possibly
can one thing you can do if you have
problems with slow test is to separate
out unit tests from acceptance tests
acceptance test do integration tests by
Nature are a lot slower particularly if
you're using the browser unit test
unlock a lot quicker it's very
frustrating for me as a developer if I
wait 20 minutes for a whole bunch of
slow except test to run to find that my
very quick unit test failed so at the
very least you can get feedback quickly
for the quick tests before you want any
the slow ones
also try to limmit the amount of
acceptance tests because the cost of
these are very slow they're slowing down
your whole team it's useful to have them
but try to limit them to only a few they
go across the whole system you should be
testing most of your functionality
already at the unit test
level so you shouldn't need to have a
shed load of acceptance as slowing
everything
down if you you find that unit test are
very slow make sure that you're not
making call to database too much I've
seen this quite often in really big
reals applications it's very easy to not
separate out active record from the
database this means that you're loading
up database with most of the unit tests
they're not actual unit tests they are
testing the interacting from the
database as well as the code and it
makes them a lot slower to run so when
you can try to moop out calls to
database and if all else fails R test in
parallel maybe on a CI
server but it's better if you can to get
tests running all on a developers
machine because even if you can run test
really quickly on some kind of C
integration server you're quite possibly
waiting in a queue before your build can
run and now again you end up back in the
same situation where you're waiting for
a long time for feedback on your tests
picking up something new maybe not
bothering to wait for your test to go
out there so quick test tweet
runs useful if you
can and just going back to lots of
acceptance again for a
minute they're they're really useful
when they test the integration of all
the systems Al together you test
features the way that user would use
them end to end but I've also seen
features that are testing much more UI
things which are actually a lot less
useful A good rule of thumb for an
acceptance test is if that test fails
would I stop releasing the production
I've seen a lot of tests that don't
actually pass that test for example I've
seen tests that fail if the heading was
not a H1 does your user actually care
about that should that really stop a
release if not that test really
shouldn't be
there next mer
H this happens if you have long running
future branches particularly if you have
lots of developers working on a really
big code base Each of which has long
running feature branches maybe for the
length of iteration at the very end of
the iteration everyone starts to merge
their branches all together and now
suddenly nothing is working the C are
tearing their hair out because they've
been testing these feature branches all
individually but now suddenly all the
branches being merge
together and everything's gone
completely crazy so ideally don't have
long lift feature branches try to put
everything into Master at least once a
day if you have features that are going
to be going on for much that need
development for more than a few
days use feature switches if you can
so keep all the code in master but just
turn on the feature when it's ready to
go or if your the code that you want to
change is much too wide ranging for that
Branch by
abstraction so put an interface across
the thing that you want to
change create a new thing under the new
interface when it's good to go SW swap
it back in there
again continuous
integration it's more often than you
think you have a whole bunch of long
running Fe feature branches you are not
not testing integration between all your
code you're only testing integration
between your feature branch and
master don't find that out at the end of
the releationship before you want to go
live that's far too
late so the main point of this talk has
really been about speeding up your cycle
time you don't necessarily have to go to
continuous deployment it may be that for
your organization just speeding up with
s a little bit is actually fine so what
counts as a quick cycle time it really
depends on your industry and what your
competitors are up to so if your cycle
time is a couple of weeks but your
competive cycle time is a couple of days
and oh you probably have some work to
get a bit quicker but if your cycle time
is a couple of days this is a couple of
months you're
fine it's actually not necessary to get
a lot better than that but if you're in
a situation where you really have to go
quicker when you've already fixed the
rest of your bottlenecks and you want to
start getting a bit closer to deployment
itself here are a couple thoughts about
how to do that the first thing is there
is no magic tool that will help you get
to contined deployment a lot of it is
again working out what humans are
currently doing what decision points are
that humans have used to get those
decisions
so this slide it's not about moving QA
this slide is about removing as much as
possible the manual QA step in between
code being chok in and code getting out
to
production so the work that cures are
doing moved early in the process so
ideally what they're doing now it's
working with developers when a story
starts CES will get together with
developers to discuss what test should
be with if you have technical kind of QA
maybe the QA actually write the
acceptance or inte test themselves if
they don't they will certainly be
discussing with the developers what test
should be there and when the story is
done the Cur will be sitting with the
developer while the developer shows how
it works and what the test
are and making sure that the story is
actually tested and the C are also
involved with setting the performance
test so setting setting scenarios Cur
are great at working out the kind of
things that might break the system so
that they should really be writing a lot
of automatic tests to catch these
things computers are really good at
doing a whole bunch of automatic things
over and over and over like like these
kind of tests but humans are really good
at exploratory testing they're figuring
out the we the weird and lacky things
users might be doing for the system
that's going to break it so that's what
the Cur should be concentrating
on at the guardian we had a massive
manual automat manual testing process
that the QA did so a lot of the features
that made the guardian CMS so really
useful actually made it incredibly
difficult to test the content management
system had hundreds of templates and
each of those templates could have
hundreds of components placed on them
those components and templates were in
Contin were continuously being updated
and changed led to POS possible millions
of pages being changed every time a
deploy went out it's not possible for
any human to check them all it's
actually really difficult for any
computer to check them all either
because a lot of the changes it wasn't
that the page wouldn't load it's much
more that the page would look kind of
strange things would be styled wrong the
fonts would be off the spacing would be
off a journalist really really care
about fonts and
spacing much more than I do
so you you we would get calls yeah last
but least the font the font size is
completely wrong in this page like it's
a
massive so there there was a an
outsourced team because we didn't have
the cre capacity to do the amount of
tests across all these Pages we didn't
try to test all all the millions of
pages we certainly try to test a very
big subset of the pages there's this
massive Outsource team which I think
that's the total Cur time every released
was something like two weeks of of man
hours which is condensed into two days
but even that what we found we didn't
actually catch the problems because
there are so many potential places what
the curos would be doing they just
playing catch up every time so it never
broke last time they' be testing again
this time but we knew that we we checked
that already when we're doing our
development so that's not thing it's
going to break it's a whole different
thing it's going to break this
time we did some evaluation of how the C
process was going and actually it just
really wasn't working at all even though
we had a whole bunch of people they
weren't really catching useful issues
so the fix for this was first of all to
stop having quite that many
templates there was anyway a massive
rewrite of the CMS in progress I think
it has just gone live now which is very
exciting it has massively simplified
things because the the templates and
components were not only really
complicated to test they were really
complicated to use so it was much too
complicated for any one journalist to
keep the whole thing in their head
anyway the second thing was just to stop
trying to test that many pages there a a
lot of them even though they're millions
of pages users only really care about a
a small subset of that they don't care
about most of them so in the end what
the care process came down to was test
only the pages that the users really
care about so test the most popular
pages and for the rest of them if
there's a release and we change we broke
something on a really popular page the
users would tell us about it if we broke
something in a release no one told us
about it for 3 months well in that case
I'm probably going to delete it because
no one really knows it for three months
so why is this saying Sol that Shing up
my
CMS or in other
words it's not possible to to catch
everything before it gets to production
even with the best tests that you have
even with the biggest pray resource that
you ever going to
have things are always going to get
through just because they are it's much
better for the
users if when there is a bug if you can
fix it quickly that is if your cycle
time is quickly you can get you can get
things moving with your system quickly
and fix it quickly than to spend huge C
effort trying to catch everything
because you never can that's the lesson
that we eventually learned at the
guarding taking the human out
performance
tests this is really about working at
what criteria that the humans use right
now to work out whether the performance
is good at the guardian for a long time
we used to look at graphs uh human would
look at the graph and decide if that
graph is good enough for the C
production uh the trouble is that humans
are kind of subjective in the way they
make decisions and they two humans are
going to make the same decision when
looking at the same graphs it's actually
really interesting when we all got
together decided what the true success
criteria were for the
graphs then once we decided that we
could actually automated so rather than
doing a graph we
could
um have have ranges acceptable ranges
defined by all the Developers for when a
release is good enough to get production
perance is good
enough so for automatic performance test
tests have a performance test
environment that is a scale down replica
of
production make sure that those
performance tests accurately reflect
what's going on in
production Define application specific
metrics you should have these already if
you've already got your your monitoring
going on then use that
here even though whatever performance
test tools you're doing will give you
some kind of basic graphs it's actually
really interesting to see how your
application metrics behave when your
systems under load so make sure that you
have that and then that's buil into your
performance
tests and
lastly automating releas
process this is much more about making
it easy to to launch and to roll back
maybe about adding some Canary test in
so you now have your application metrix
you know how they perform under load it
should be really easy now to write
something that you uses this application
metrix to work out if latest release is
doing well in production or not and if
not if you have Canary tests it can do
an automatic roll back if the rest of
production is not doing well it can it
can alert you to tell you that
something's going
wrong oh and if you have feature
switches then it's even easier when your
application magic telling you that
something's going really badly wrong
just turn your feature off
easy so in summary measure your time fix
your botle Tex improve your reaction
time
[Applause]
questions and if you want some homework
there's some suggestions up there for
further reading are there any
questions hi um so I'd like that you
address the issue with the the database
prerequisites on your releases in the
past I've had a lot of problems doing
Canary releases or betas because um uh
schema had to be changed at release time
um the thing is it seems like uh we
would get push back um where it was like
oh we can't change the schema because we
don't know what features are going to be
asked for and when you have you get push
back from the business it says oh this
is Agile development right we we kind of
expected the feature to be complete in
one spring um and you're telling me it's
going to take three Sprints or four
Sprints for this feature to release
because you have to change the database
schema now obviously that's kind of like
a a business type problem but do you
have any more feedback on on that
particular
problem so in general when we're doing
schema change we be doing on a feature
by feature
basis so you can't make any schema
changes if you don't know what you're
going to be doing yet so I would make
them at the point at the point only when
you know exactly what schema change is
necessary and before the code is written
for that thing
we would just get a lot of you know it
would be like
well we don't want to wait three Sprints
for this to actually release because you
know uh anyway yeah I'm sorry I can't
explain it very you know what I mean
like like they would like the the the
the schema change and the the production
release change had to happen the same
release because of
uh business demands and the only thing I
came up with with was like version stor
procedures like oh here's store
procedure version 1 here's St procedure
same store procedure version 2 you
anything have any feedback on that I was
try procedure as much as possible and
try to put switches in the code if you
can so if you got to have code that
works with different versions of a
database which does sometimes happen
particularly if you're doing multiple
staged things okay then I would try and
switch the code as much as possible
partly partly I don't like s procedures
partly because they're hidden I don't
like things that do things without me
expecting them they're quite easy to get
hidden and to confuse people that makes
perfect sense and you don't want to it's
a pain to version release and
synchronize them but sometimes when it
comes
to uh latency issues you really need to
store procedur so you're not bouncing
back these connections but anyway yeah
some some things are hard some things
have to get done across multiple
releases or multiple changes it can be
hard to
coordinate any else hell do you have
typical advis strategies for other team
in terms of committing someone
to um as in 10 to 15 15 to 20 uh size
teams uh you know there some lar teams
large
teams people to yeah what is your typal
recation for terms ofit someone as oppos
to sharing responsibility among
developers so I would generally say that
devops isn't a team it's a role it's
it's I would say devops is not a team
it's a role
yell Lou
devops not it's a role it's it's not a
team so it's it's operations working
together with developers there's no
right sized amount of people other than
everybody the entire it really works
better if the whole com whole
development team is devops so they're
just all working closely together it's
much more about shared ownership so
rather than operations owning production
and developers owning the code but
everybody owning everything and working
much closer together so say the right
size for devops is the the development
team all of
them hi
I'm what if you even have what are your
OPP those
twoes don't exist and after check start
with
I guess pretty much the same whatever
you can do to speed up the cycle time so
what is it that is taking all the time
to get production is TR the CL it's j
the slowest step that you have right now
in which case start there what is it
taking all the time is it that it's not
automated can you start automate
something gradually automated get get it
quicker keep measuring all of cycle time
make sure that the whole thing is
increasing just keep
going
had
um said don't VI long those branches
instead uh Branch by abstraction yeah
put so future switches are really great
as long as feature switches don't go
across too much of the code base
sometimes if the if the code that is
checking for the fature starts getting
too spread out it's quite it's quite a
pain to manage it's quite a pain to take
it out at the end so if you're changing
a really big part of your code base then
try and hide it by the interface
so um you have an interface for but the
current impementation behind the
interface is that now develop the new
thing which also follows the interface
as well and then at the point when
you're good to go swap them over and
then Del the interface at the end so
you're good to go of when I have my
branches I'm actually try to introduce
new
interface
that can be
hard yeah these things are
hard was that should we go night is that
it to call it
okay